up high on the roof of Rochester
cathedral in what looks like a cleanup
operation
our planetary scientists looking for
answers about life in outer space
on these large roofs researchers are
collecting debris from the cosmos the
sites are largely undisturbed over many
years
equipped with a special vacuum cleaner
medieval Cathedrals like this one are
proving to be an ideal hunting ground
for researchers on the lookout for
Cosmic dust
the micrometers from roofs usually are
very fresh so you get all the
information you need is like they felt
yesterday
so to me it's always very surprising to
see how fresh they are because the
fresher the better the more information
you have and it's these events that hold
the key meteorites and comets that turn
into tiny particles on impact with the
Earth's atmosphere
any material gathered on the cathedral
roof could provide answers to the
origins of our solar system if
successful it would mean that this place
of worship would be a portal to the
heavens
more than 100 million of micro
meteorites land on Earth every year
while our own solar system is 4.6
billion years old some of the oldest
particles that have been discovered date
back 7 billion years all of the
particles that arrive we think on the
Earth's surface come from the asteroids
so the asteroids these are typically
found on orbits around the Sun between
the orbits of Mars and the orbits of
Jupiter and so those objects some of
them are thought to be really old
the research by the school of physical
sciences of the University of Kent will
go on to form the basis of a citizen
science-based project
and the hope is that it will spur public
interest in space science as well as
provide an answer to what's out there
Sonic Gallego Al Jazeera Rochester